en términos digamos objetivos y desde la
normativa legal vigente las políticas
públicas que ha podido impulsar el
gobierno del presidente por cierto que
no hemos logrado resolver los problemas
que generaron o the descent formaron
digamos ya staron es también tan tan
confuso y conflictivo que nos llevó a
este estadio social el año 2019 muchas
de esas debilidades de esas
desigualdades del sistema político o del
sistema de la garantía de los derechos
fundamentales sigue estando igual e
igual de dificultosa ahora que se debe
esto y porque yo creo que también una
coyuntura que influyó en este resultado
y que también influyó en la ciudadanía
yo yo le restaría tantos méritos digamos
a lo que ocurrió con la pública
publicidad de la campaña de la prueba en
rechace tantas noticias falsas ciertos
signos como las grandes causantes
de que perdiera la prueba y ganar el
rechazo yo creo que si bien fue un
factor no fue el factor clave
precisamente el hecho de que las
desigualdades sigan vigentes
sigan presentes es cierto que el
gobierno el presidente o derecha esté
intentando aplicar una agenda de cambio
pero que va a ser muy lenta e influyó
cierto es la situación en una
inseguridad a la ciudadanía a la que tú
tienes que sumarle dos años de pandemia
en esos dos años de pandemia ciertos
alteraron como en todos los países
alteraron todos los estándares
económicos sociales de desarrollo
etcétera etcétera y ahora estamos viendo
de nuevo proceso económico bien complejo
una recesión económica con una inflación
un tanto alta y todo esto generó como un
contexto político muy complejo para
quizás la ciudadanía tomar la decisión
de atreverse a ir a implementar un texto
tan transformador como es el borrador de
la nueva constitución